it's sort of funny kind of insane a
little crazy how in the world of Trump
we've referenced FoxNews Mitt Romney
some Republicans and even george w bush
as comparative voices of reason truly
stunning and it happened yesterday with
george w bush again former president
george w bush was interviewed on NBC's
Today Show and slammed Donald Trump on
his war against the media and said
unequivocally that yes we need answers
about what's going on with Trump and
Russia and it's so obvious that even
George W Bush gets it I'm not suggesting
we bring back george w bush's some
arbiter of what does or doesn't make
sense
he still has as you'll notice in this
clip that slightly confused smirk on his
face suggesting that he just woke up and
people were just in his room asking him
questions when he's being interviewed
but still at least on this issue he
seems to get it telling Matt Lauer in
this first clip that media is
indispensable between me do an
interesting point because you are a guy
who faced both praise and criticism from
the media during your time in office
even at the times where you were dealing
with the worst criticism where it must
have been very difficult to hear and
read some of the things that were being
said by the press in this country did
you ever consider the media to be the
enemy of the American people I consider
the media media to be indispensable to
democracy that we need an independent
media to hold people like me to account
I mean power can be very addictive and
it can be corrosive and it's important
for the media to call to account people
who abuse their power it's hard for me
to get past that dumb smirk that we've
come to know so well it's hard for me to
get past all of the disasters that
george w bush did as president but his
right power can be addictive and
corrosive and media is important in that
context what he was also asked about
Donald Trump and Russia and he was also
right about that dumb smirk
notwithstanding take a look
you mentioned Vladimir Putin so many
questions about the contacts between
Trump associates during the campaign and
the Russian government as a former
president would you like to see a
special prosecutor appointed to look
to this once and for all and give the
American people answers well first of
all I think I think we all need answers
whether or not the special prosecutor is
the right way to go - now you're talking
to the wrong guy
I have great faith in Richard Burr for
example he's a head of the Senate
Intelligence Committee really good guy
and an independent thinker and you know
if he were to recommend a special
prosecutor than I could I'd be you know
I then I have a lot more credibility
with me but I'm really and I've never
been a lawyer you know I'm not sure the
right Avenue to take I am sure though
that that question needs to be answered
we all need answers that question needs
to be answered a former Republican
president is saying that definitively
without question the issue of the
current Republican presidents ties to a
foreign power Russia need to be answered
if Donald Trump is making Republicans
sound this reasonable and I'm not
suggesting we start going to george w
bush and cheer cheering championing him
in any way he's done something of
massive magnitude trump as if even
george w bush is the voice of reason
against the Republican president I mean
I really don't find it too surprising
that george w bush is kind of
criticizing Trump here in this graceful
southern way you could say because
during the campaign trail Trump would
just go after bush all the time
especially when it came to the war in
Iraq
yeah even called him a liar when it came
to claiming there were weapons of mass
destruction there which is further than
even a lot of Democrats were willing to
go and then also I mean he just made a
fool out of Bush's brother Jeb remedial
ease Low Energy
the phrase created to describe Jeb Bush
III think George W Bush has taken as
many shots at Trump in Trump's first
five weeks now as president then george
w bush stood against obama for an
eight-year period when you leave behind
two wars and a major economic depression
i guess you start painting pictures not
criticizing the guy who comes in to
clean up your mess but okay so Bush said
he's okay with a Republican controlling
the possible investigation into Trump
that's a detail I would take issue with
but this is very very big and you'll
remember that george w bush has become
basically non-existent in Republican
circles his presidency was such a train
wreck that he didn't really help the
McCain
campaign in 2008 he was totally missing
from Mitt Romney's 2012 campaign and the
truth is that real criticism of Trump
has to come from other Republicans when
you've got Republicans controlling the
House and Senate and and a former
president is at the top of that list of
people that maybe will be listened to by
trumpets in terms of their criticisms
I'm not saying you know Bush was a train
wreck right the fact that he happens to
see the absurdity of what's going on
with Trump it doesn't mean I want him
sticking around I'd rather him just
paint the pictures in his bathtub but
this is powerful that he is saying this
I mean it's crazy that the Trump
administration is almost making you miss
a war criminal in George W Bush stunning
but I think Trump is actually worth
absolutely stunning and I think you're
absolutely right